this is cereth registered nurse re and
calm and in this video i'm going to be
going over blood transfusions which will
include the nurses role and as always
I've been to this YouTube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this procedure so let's get started
what is a blood transfusion it is where
as a nurse we will transfuse a patient
who is low on red blood cells with new
red blood cells via a venous access of
some type now this is most commonly done
through donated red blood cells so a
patient needs them some ones donated
them to the blood bank and as a nurse we
will hang a bag of red blood cells for
the patient and transfuse them to
replace those low red blood cells which
answers the question why would a patient
need a blood transfusion because they're
low on red blood cells and what can
cause a person to be low on red blood
cells well number one blood loss and
they've had some type of surgery or
trauma they can lose a lot of blood so
we have to replenish them with red blood
cells or they're anemic they can have
anemia so bad that they need blood
transfusions at some point like because
they don't produce enough red blood
cells and this can happen in conditions
like renal failure cancers just to name
a few because the body is not producing
enough substances to produce or maintain
those red blood cells now what's the
importance of red blood cells they are
very vital for our survival and how our
body works so in other words our body
can't function very well without them so
what a red blood cells do with the help
of hemoglobin it carries oxygen it
receives from the lungs throughout our
body in addition it removes carbon
dioxide co2 and it will take that take
it to the lungs so the lungs can't
exhale it therefore whenever your
patient is low on red blood cells
they're going to have some side
symptoms that can present especially if
they're really low they'll be very pail
I've seen patients they literally look
white as a sheet before the transfusion
and then after the transfusion I've told
all my patients man you look like you
got a tan because they their skin color
is back to where it should be
so it's really interesting you transfuse
blood make sure you look at that another
thing is they can feel very fatigued
they can be short of breath any activity
they're just like really wore out and
they can have an increased heart rate be
tachycardic because that heart is trying
to pump that blood because consents of
the oxygen is low so it's like I got to
get more blood everywhere else so it can
overwork itself so when is a patient
transfuse well this really depends
depends on what's going on with the
patient their vital signs how are they
tolerating that low blood level and
recent guidelines by the American
Association of blood banks recommends
transfusing blood when hemoglobin levels
fall to 7 to 8 grams per deciliter so
then what is a normal hemoglobin level
well depends if you're male or female
Mel's it's 14 to 18 grams per deciliter
in females it's 12 to 16 grams per
deciliter now let's look at the nurses
roll with transfusing blood now
transfusing blood is very common in the
hospital setting and you not only need
to know this for NCLEX your Nursing
lecture exams but you need to know it
for the job okay the first thing before
a patient is even transfused is a lot of
prep work that is super important and
essential because our prep work helps
prevent transfusion reactions so we want
to make sure we follow exactly what we
need to and hospitals have in place
protocols that whenever you become a new
grad you start working you want to read
over there protocol and make sure that
you follow it exactly
now most hospitals require that you're a
registered nurse in order to transfuse
the blood so again follow your Hospital
protocol with that so let's say you got
an order for
patient to be transfused with two units
of packed red blood cells what's the
very first thing that's going to be done
the patient is going to be type and
cross-match either you'll be drawing the
blood or your phlebotomist will be
drawing it and this is the part where
you've got to pay special attention to
everything from what you write down to
how you identify the patient you place
the blood band everything must be done
perfectly because we don't want do too
like some type of clerical error to
cause a transfusion reaction because
someone messed up which tends to be the
most common reason for a transfusion
reaction so always take care whenever
this has to be done next send the blood
labs going to type in blood bank will
match the blood with a donor and we'll
prepare the amount of blood that you're
going to need now it's also important
that as the nurse you know the patient's
[ __ ] compatibility and their Rh factors
what blood they can receive what blood
they can't receive and I have a whole
video where I went over that in depth
with you and you can access that and
take a quiz that can test you on that
but just a quick review who is the
universal donor who can donate to all
types that's oh now who is the universal
recipient they can take from everyone
that's a B next you'll want to get
informed consent tell the patient what
they're going to be receiving assess
their understanding of it also this is a
good time to ask about their allergies
and if they have received any blood
transfusions in the past and if they
have how many because if they have
received a lot of blood transfusions in
the past they're at risk for febrile nan
hemolytic transfusion reaction where
their body has just built up these
antibodies from all those previous
transfusions and they can start running
a fever and things like that so a lot of
times physicians like to pre medicate
them and you'll want to let the
physician know if they do have a history
of that and sometimes they're
pre-medicated with benadryl or Tylenol
acetaminophen before hand orally or when
about 30 minutes before you start the
transfusion and that will help prevent
that also look at the health status of
your patient are you giving a patient
who is in fluid overload or congestive
heart failure has renal failure and but
they really need blood you need to be
looking at that because they may be at
risk for circulatory overload where you
can put them in fluid overload because
you're putting all this blood inside of
their body so a lot of times physicians
may order lasix some type of loop
diuretic before the transfusion or in
between the units or after the
transfusion so you want to be aware of
that as well next you want to make sure
your patient has IV access we have to
get this blood in then and you typically
want an 18-gauge or larger IV site some
hospitals again it's varies on protocols
they'll allow you to transfuse through a
twenty engage and why is that well as
those red blood cells are shooting
through they're going into the system if
that cannula is not large enough those
red blood cells can break open they can
lysis and you're just breaking them up
and they're not really going into the
patient's body so you want good IV
access another thing you really want to
consider is you know it takes anywhere
between two to four hours for a unit of
blood to transfuse well if you have to
hang some antibiotics on this patient or
they're gonna need some IV drugs you
can't use that IV access that is being
used for the blood transfusion so you
need a second access so keep that in
mind it's always good to just have a
good two sites while a patient's needing
blood next is supplies whenever you
transfuse blood you use special tubing
which is called Y tubing with an inline
filter which helps filter some of those
substances out of the blood before it
actually goes to the patient and keep in
mind again it depends on hospital
protocol a lot of protocols say only one
set of Y tubing per unit that you
transfuse so you'll have to you're going
to transfuse the patient with more than
one unit
multiple sets or some hospitals say it's
only good for four hours so keep that in
mind when you need to change your filter
your tubing next you'll want to grab a
bag of normal saline 0.9 percent of
normal saline this is the only only
solution you ever use whenever
transfusing blood you never use any met
other medications or any other fluids
only saline remember that because say
you gave it with a dextrose containing
solution dextrose and red blood cells
don't get along it can cause them to
clump up together so only 0.9% normal
saline and we will be using that saline
to prime that why tubing whip and then
to flush that tubing with afterwards
once the blood is done transfusing and
in addition just whenever everything's
wrapped up you're ready to take that
tubing down you'll need to get a red
biohazard bag to dispose of it properly
again fall your Hospital protocols for
holiday dispose of their blood products
but um you never ever put it in the
regular trash now let's talk about
transfusing okay done all your prep work
the blood bank calls you and says hey
your blood is ready let us know whenever
you're ready for us to send it to you
because they're keeping it refrigerated
for you so some key things you want to
remember you will be giving one unit at
a time patient needs two units
you're gonna give one unit now and then
whenever that's done call blood bank and
say send me the other unit and then
they'll send it to you so one at a time
and from the time that the person brings
you your blood or you go and collect it
you need to start transfusing no later
than within twenty to thirty minutes and
it needs to be done that unit needs to
be done within two to four hours so why
is this well from the time that that
blood bag leaves the refrigerator it
needs to be in the patient's body within
no more than four hours because there's
a risk of it developing bacteria and we
can give the patient septicemia
so you want to transfuse it in that time
frame also another thing you just want
to consider one
throw this out there is notify the blood
bank that you're ready for the blood
when you're ready because you need to
get this in and as a nurse you get your
blood so you have mission discharge you
have a patient that is just not doing
good that 30 minutes flies fast and you
have this blood and you haven't even
given it and now it's like 35 minutes
later well you can't give it you're
gonna have to send it back to the blood
bank and blood is expensive so notify
the blood bank whenever you're ready to
start that transfusion now blood wormers
blood warmers can be used if the patient
needs large amounts of blood quickly and
they're at risk for experiencing
hypothermic response so you're not gonna
warm the blood up by using a microwave
or anything like that you want to use a
special device if need be next before
you even start the transfusion you're
gonna be doing this verification process
so as the nurse you're gonna be getting
another nurse it's usually to our ends
cuz ourian's are usually the ones who
can transfuse and then you're gonna do
another verification process with
another orient and you're going to be
looking at the following things before
the transfusion together you're going to
be verifying that physician's order
you're going to be looking at the
patient's identification versus the
blood banks information making sure
everything matches up perfectly
you're gonna look look at the patient's
blood type versus the donors tie and the
Rh factor you're gonna make sure that
they're compatible next you're gonna
look at the expiration day on the blood
make sure it's not expired you're gonna
look at the blood make sure it doesn't
have any clots are abnormal substances
in the blood or it's damaged in any way
and everything must match perfectly and
if there's a discrepancy you'll need to
notify the blood bank immediately and
just from personal experience this has
happened with one of my patients I was
doing the whole verification process
with another nurse and we were looking
at the blood bag looking at the
patient's ID band looking up and there
was one letter that they had did a
clerical error on so I had to send the
blood
and we had to go through the whole
process again so this does happen so
always make sure you verify everything
also before transfusing you're going to
be getting baseline vital signs which is
going to include the temperature the
blood pressure respirations and heart
rate you want to make sure those are
within normal limits and especially that
temperature if you have a temperature
greater than a hundred degrees
Fahrenheit you'll want to notify the
physician and make sure they just want
to still proceed with the blood
transfusion then again before you
actually transfuse you want to explain
to your patient if they're alert and
oriented they can talk to you what
you're about to do and for them to
notify and report to you if they feel
any of the signs and symptoms I'm fixing
to describe because it can be a
transfusion reaction like sweating
chills chest pain itching short of
breath headache backache or nausea and
vomiting and if this happens you'll
immediately want to stop the transfusion
okay now it's actually time to start the
transfusion so you're gonna have your
blood ready hung and it's going to be
controlled by an infusion pump which
will deliver it to the patient and you
want to start the transfusion slowly
about two milliliters per minute for
those first 15 minutes in addition you
want to stay with that patient at their
bedside looking at them monitoring them
for those first 15 minutes and why is
that why are you doing that
well you're writing up slowly because we
want to minimize the amount of blood
that the patient's going to receive in
case they do have a possible transfusion
reaction we can turn that blood off and
we want to stay with them during the
first 15 minutes because that's when
most transfusion reactions occur so
we're gonna be watching their bottle
signs throughout so you're gonna stay
with them after five minutes of starting
the transfusion you're going to get
bottle signs and again this is depending
on your hospital protocol and then after
that you'll get them at 15 minutes after
the transfusion has started and if the
patient's okay they're tolerating it
well this is the time that you can
increase the rate and remember you want
to make sure that that unit that bag of
blood goes in within four hours no more
than four hours then you'll get it to 30
minutes again and then hourly until done
and then one hour after the transfusion
and throughout that blood transfusion
you're going to be monitoring them for
of course a transfusion reaction and
transfusion reaction that word is like
an umbrella term for a lot of different
reactions the patient can have and here
in a moment we're gonna go in-depth over
those but it's where the recipient that
patients immune system is interacting
with the donors blood so you can have a
hemolytic transfusion reaction where
what's happening is that the patient's
blood and the donors blood are not
compatible and immune system is
attacking that donors red blood cells
that they're receiving and this is
dangerous it can lead to death also
allergic they can have a febrile which
is non hemolytic or GVHD
which is graft-versus-host disease and
have an Astra cry this because this
tends to happen days two weeks after a
blood transfusion it's rare and it's
deadly if it does happen and in addition
you want to monitor your patient for
what's called circulatory overload and
which patients do you think would be at
risk for this think of any patient
that's at risk for whenever you put
extra fluid volume in their blood
they'll have trouble with it like
patients who have heart problems like
congestive heart failure their heart
muscles weak and you just throw that
extra fluid in it it can't do well with
it so the fluid starts backing up into
the lungs and into the tissues they have
breathing trouble things like that also
patients who have renal failure
you know these patients need blood but
their risk for being able to tolerate
all that fluid going in there so you
want to keep that in mind you do have to
transfuse these patients who have that
in addition we want to monitor them for
septicemia now it's in a way on how we
can remember all those big signs and
symptoms that your patient may be having
a transfusion reaction so to help us to
remember those major signs and symptoms
let's remember the word reaction okay r4
rash they may have a rash or
fives efore elevated temperature and
what you want to do is you want to look
at that baseline
temperature and you need to ask yourself
how's it increase and if you're
measuring in Fahrenheit has it increased
1.8 degrees or if you're recording in
Celsius has it increase one degree from
baseline if so think transfusion
reaction a 418 is your patient saying I
have a backache all of a sudden or I'm
having chest pain or my head is hurting
that's a red flag c-4 chills t4
tachycardia especially if it's really
increased from baseline I for increased
respirations same thing with that
increase from baseline oh for all glory
so you really want to be looking at your
patients urinary output during this
blood transfusion and after are they
putting out low or are they just putting
out no urine at all are they an Urich
and then look at the color what does it
look like are they experiencing a
condition called hemoglobinuria
where there's free hemoglobin in the
urine it will have like this purplish
color so watch the earring closely and
then in for nausea GI issues like
diarrhea then when the transfusions done
your patients tolerated it well you'll
want to flush that remaining blood out
of that line with that saline that's
hanging on that Y tubing then dispose of
your tubing properly and then collect
post vital signs one hour after that
transfusion now let's take a closer look
at those various transfusion reactions
and then talk about what you're going to
do as a nurse if your patient does have
a transfusion reaction during a blood
transfusion
okay first hemolytic this is where the
immune system is killing the donors red
blood cells so what's happened
antibodies in the recipients blood match
that antigens on the donors blood cells
so hence they've been missed tight and
this can lead to di C and renal failure
and even death and a lot of times what's
going to happen is you're gonna see a
fever chills anxiety back pain chest
pain hemoglobinuria where you have that
purplish look to the urine also they can
be
tachycardic and have a low blood
pressure another type is called allergic
and this is where the recipients immune
system is reacting to the proteins found
in the donors blood leading to like
rashes hives and itching and it can
actually progress to in a flexus and the
patient with this can have hives rashes
respiratory issues like wheezing oral
swelling things that you expect whenever
someone's having an anaphylactic
reaction to something another type is
febrile and this is non hemolytic so you
don't have the breaking up of those red
blood cells like you did in hemolytic
but this is where the recipients white
blood cells or reacting with the donors
white blood cells and this causes the
body to build antibodies so you can see
that increased temperature like one
degree Celsius or one point eight degree
in Fahrenheit from the baseline and this
is actually the most common transfusion
reaction that you tend to see especially
in patients who have received blood in
the past because their body has created
these antibodies so that's what you want
to ask them have you received a lot of
transfusions before and you can see
chills headache increase heart rate and
fever with that and another transfusion
reaction you can have is the GVHD the
graft-versus-host disease and again like
I said this is rare but it's deadly and
it tends to occur days to weeks after
the transfusion so this is where the
donors T lymphocytes cause an immune
response in the recipient but actually
in grasping in the marrow of the
recipient and attacking the recipients
tissue so these T lymphocytes are
usually killed by the recipients body
but however maybe the patient has a
suppressed immune system and they didn't
attack these t lymphocytes whenever
they're getting the transfusion and
these hea lymphocytes from the donors
start attacking that marrow and what can
happen is they can have a fever
and this really peculiar rash all over
the body it'll be on the hands and the
feet as well with GI issues diarrhea
nausea inflammation of the liver and you
want to talk you want to tell your
patient you know if you start having
this rash from head
the this fever diarrhea all this stuff
for several weeks after you've had this
blood transfusion you want to report
that to your doctor other complications
that can arise that really aren't immune
related
it's like septicemia where the blood is
contaminated so as a nurse again it's
really important that you start that
transfusion promptly after receiving it
from the blood bank or the blood is
contaminated with a disease now this
isn't as common because we have strict
screening guidelines but there can be a
risk for hepatitis B C or HIV etc also
that circuit or e overload we are
talking about or developing high iron
levels and this happens with people
who've had frequent blood transfusions
now let's talk about if your patient
does have a blood transfusion reaction
and I have seen this this does happen so
keep it in the back of your mind so the
first thing what you want to do is stop
the transfusion and you want to note
mentally what time this occurred what
time you stopped it because you'll be
documenting this later on also you're
going to disconnect the blood tubing at
the access side and replace it with new
tubing and have some point nine percent
normal saline running to keep the vein
open then you're going to notify the
doctor and the blood bank of what's
going on but during all this you're
going to be staying with the patient at
their bedside you need be watching them
you need your eyes on them so this is a
great time to call in other people on
the floor to be helping you make these
phone calls to be doing these things
next you're going to be monitoring those
vital signs every five minutes looking
at them watching them looking at that
respiratory status it's not compromised
or they have an allergic response what's
going on now whenever you contact the
physician depending on what type of
reaction they suspect the patient's
having or how severe it is what's going
on they may order some medication so it
varies some things they can orders like
corticosteroids which is going to
suppress that immune response
along with fluids helping flush out
that free hemoglobin that's in the body
getting it out we want out of the body
anti hit anti histamines to decrease
that immune response anti-pirate ik stu
decrease that temperature vasopressors
this can help if there have an allergic
response like epinephrine to open up the
airways there's a lot of time those
Airways clamp down and they can't
breathe or like dopamine to increase
renal blood flow or diuretics also some
labs are going to be ordered they want
to look at those claudine levels because
remember if this is hemolytic type
because a lot of times they don't know
what type of reaction this patient is
having they want to look at those
clotting factors because they're at risk
for di C where all their clotting
factors are just going to be depleted
and they can bleed out and die looking
at those electrolytes looking at the
renal function how's our kidneys and
other blood levels in addition you'll be
collecting urine urine on them looking
for the free hemoglobin that's came from
those red blood cells I have lysis and
whenever you are disconnecting your
tubing over here do not throw it away
don't throw any of it away because
you'll be sending that one with the
leftover blood and any other
documentation to the blood bank
who's going to test it look out and see
what went wrong and of course you're
going to document you want to document
the time it happened what actions you
took what the patient was given if you
gave them anything what labs you drew
all that and how the patient is
currently doing okay so that wraps up
this review over blood transfusion thank
you so much for watching don't forget to
take the free quiz and to subscribe to
our channel for more videos